this photo has been traveling for quite
a while nineteen hundred and something
and today you met up and the situation
was the hairy contemporary it was not an
old photo it was made a long time ago
but it is a new photo that's very much
about what is the role of the libraries
in our world today are we thinking of a
library as well I'm going to travel into
the past and we're just going into an
archive yes and the classical
objectifying sort of and and and and if
the repast relative to the presence but
it's very interesting it's an
unbelievably interesting question I of
course think that the past is as
relative as the future because our
perspective keeps changing and that
gives agency to the future for the
library the library these photos are in
fact an opportunity to travel into the
future as well it's a little more work
than just consuming them as a well as
great a nice ship that's nice ship let's
move on yeah and of course we need the
assistance of the great scientist who
runs the library to learn how to use the
library as a proactive rather than an a
retro